actress Samira why they gain fans when
she played the beloved character poussey
Washington and the hit series orange is
the new black while she's found more
success in her role as Moira in The
Handmaid's Tale yesterday it was renewed
go you guys for a third season some good
news for the show and its viewers the
drama series is based on the best
selling novel by Margaret Atwood about a
dystopian future when a ruling
fundamentalist regime treats women as
property of the state season 2 follows
Moira as she establishes a new life
after escaping to Canada in the newest
episode she helps another refugee get
help and adjust to his new life I was in
the Army logistics and Rapid Deployment
after everything they just turned us all
into guardians a week later my unit is
hanging bodies on the wall chair traders
one of them was a guy dated in college
your trauma counselors here now third
floor right out of the elevator Samira
Wylie is with us now good morning
welcome to the show so many fans and
such an arc for your character in this
new season newfound freedom in Canada
how is that affecting war this season
gosh Moira ever after having escaped
Gilead there's all these horrible things
that she's escaped and on the surface it
looks so wonderful she's gotten access
to health care she's gotten money things
that women aren't even allowed to
possess but there's also the other side
of it which is that she is a refugee in
a new country where she's never been
before and she's very lonely and it's
going through a lot of depression PTSD
from being in that horrible horrible
place
so we see her struggling with that we
see her on both sides of the line you
know it was so dark Samira last season
and they tell me that season two is even
darker and I think it's it boils down to
how much can a woman take before she
breaks yes that is that is a real
question and and we see these women in
this story
Moira also offered we see them being
broken down over and over and over again
but one thing we do see is them getting
back up you only take it how do you how
do you prepare for a character like that
has gone through so much trauma it's
yeah it's it's it's for me portraying
this character a lot has to do with my
connection with Lizzie she is such an
amazing loss yes sorry Elizabeth loss
and I think I really I really find and
have found my character through our
relationship that's interesting that's
how I started the character I think just
through relationship yeah and it almost
didn't take the role I did you were
worried about being typecast how I am
pride myself for being a member of the
LGBT community and have brought poussey
to life for so many years and I didn't
want to get typecast as a gay actress I
wanted to be an actress and your wife
says stop it yes
because you know poussey and where are
two wholly different different yeah you
know what I mean they're not the same
thing at all and I love that being able
to show two completely three-dimensional
did she convince you what did she say
she had no idea but she's like a huge
fan of Margaret Atwood and handmade sell
was one of her favorite books so she
basically was just like you need to take
this one and what what part of the
current times that we live in you
mentioned refugee you talked about
Canada what part of the current times we
live in do you bring to obviously what
is a fictional show and fictional
character yeah honestly it's it's it's
really everywhere in the show the the
parallels between even just what the
scripts make you feel but I think for me
specifically in the for the storyline of
Moira this season it's the refugee story
and trying to you know the show talked a
lot with the UN trying to figure trying
to make that experience authentic so
yeah well I can tell you this I reached
out to Lizzie also known as though there
was mom that's holder you were gonna be
on today and this is what she said
sameiras episode just went up and she
has some amazing things this year oh man
one of her scenes later on I burst into
tears when I watched it it's been such
an inspiration to watch her this year
give it everything she has every time
and you can quote me that's what she
said about you she's amazing that is so
so so sweet what does this role mean to
you and when you compare it to poussey
in this Rhino with two totally different
characters but what does it mean to you
to be able to see the reach that this
show has and to be able to understand
that the platform that we've been given
we suddenly have an audience people who
are listening to us and I change things
for you
it it's an incredible amount of
responsibility and it feels like I need
to just go ahead and step up to the
plate you know what I mean but it's it's
new how far-reaching this show with well
you have stepped up to the plate and hit
a home run I tell everybody it's the
best show on TV everybody thank you
acting it's amazing so much for being
witness season 2 of The Handmaid's Tale
he is streaming now on whoo